weiß man schon was in den USA h
ist immer noch nichts rausgekommen
me Bush hält sich schon mittlerweile für
den Präsidenten der USA immerhin noch
besser als Ronald Reagan der hält sich
ja inzwischen für den Gastgeber der B
SP Busch oder gur natürlich bin ich
für gur Busch mein Gott wer will
schon so einen reaktionären inzestbuben aus den
amerikanischen Süden am roten Knopf sitzen haben
so ich geb zu ich gebe ich gebe zu die
Wahl zwischen Busch und Gor das ist die
Auswahl ist nicht der Wahnsinn oder Busch
ist für Steuersenkung um für die Todesstrafe
der G ist irgendwie auch so aber er ist
umweltbewusst und ökologisch bestenfalls
kriegen wir also einen Präsidenten der
den elektrischen Stuhl solarbetrieben
einführt schon
rein wer macht sich denn Gedanken über die
Konsequenzen h ja genau ich ma mir Gedanken
die Auswirkungen auf die Wirtschaft auf die
amerikanische Wirtschaft das ist fatal Wahlzettel
raus Wahlzettel rein ganze Wirtschaftszweige
gehen zuug Grunde z.B in Florida die
feuerbestattungsindustrie die ist in den letzten
3 Wochen um über 70% gesunken ja bitteschön es
ist kein Wunder wer glaubt den da noch an letzte
Ruhe wenn da an Urnen auf und Z gemacht werden
also ja ich weiß wir Deutschen haben ganz
andere Probleme nicht wer wird sondern wer
kriegt Rinder Wahnsinn bittes schön ähm ich weiß
nicht meh was ich essen soll soll ich jetzt bei
jedem rin vorher bevor ich das irgendwie
esse vorher ein hatest machen wenn dieser
harttest positiv ist und sich diese blöde Kuh
däumlings nach Florida absetzt was tue ich dann
die kommtüber hello Chaos die schwarzen Kollegen
so jo ab WIS ihr wisst ihr was das schlimmste ist
an dieser ganzen Rinderwahnsinn Geschichte für
mich Tiermehl von Rindern wird dann wieder von
Rindern gegessen Kühe Essen Kühe ihr Lieben
Bauern ich will Kühe dieser Werbespot das war
nicht ernst gemeint nein und was sollen wir
jetzt machen jetzt dürfen sie es nicht mehr
verfüttern das Tiermehl und das Fleisch W tun
das alles hin ich sage nur statt los wochos
los knochos die verwertungswochen bei McDonald's
was bestellst du dann da einen Hamburger roal BS
eh klar knapp am Wortspiel vorbei na das ist okay
aber es sollen Schnelltest für Rinder eingeführt
werden ob die das packen das glaube ich nicht
die sind doch eh schon total verwirrt oder und
schnell apropos muss ich sagen Schnelltest für
echte deutsche Rinder die NPD wenn die haben ja
auch Einstellungstest für ihre Mitglieder
WIS das die rechtsradikale NPT die nehmen
nicht jeden da wirklich die machen ich weiß
nicht wie ich mir das vorstellen soll sitzt
da der Bundesvorsitzende Udo vug der sitzt
dann da da kommt so eine arme Glatze rein
so Kevin du willst also
Herrenmensch werden und zur Elite
gehören
also ich stell dir drei Fragen wer
wird Nazi funktioniert dann wirst
du am Schluss Funktionär also Kevin
allgemein wissen wie viel ist 1 +
1 drei ja das war knapp das lassen wir noch einmal
durchgehen ja eine leichte Frage Kevin wer war der
glorreiche Diktator der Deutschland in den 30er
Jahren zur Wohlstand und Reichtum geführt hat
eine kleine hilfstellung es war ein
Österreicher der Name fängt mit H an
hört mit er auf vielleicht noch eine
kleine Hilfestellung ha in der Mitte
ist noch ein ier Heide ja das lassen
wir noch mal durchgehen ja das war
[Musik] knapp
Kevin Kevin letzte Frage hab B du Funktionär also
was sagen wir von der NPT wenn
wir gefragt werden ob wir Nazis
sind a was sagen wir wenn wir gefragt werden darf
ich da den Joker nehmen und meine Mama anrufen wi
ihr Rechte Gefahr rinderwahnsin irgendwo besteht
da ein kleiner link ich habe ihn noch nicht aber
es sagt uns keiner die Wahrheit ist das mal
aufgefallen diese ganze Scheiße wir erfahren
alles als letzte und das fängt nicht im großen
an das fängt im ganz kleinen an in der Erziehung
sind wahrscheinlich viele Eltern hier ihr hab
Kinder was hören wir oft für Scheiße von den
Eltern schon am Anfang du bist 12 Jahre alt
du denkst hey jetzt entdecke ich die Welt
ganz alleine meinen Körper fängst du an WIS ja
mein Vater hat mich damals mal dabei erwischt
ja da kam der ins Zimmer da kommen diese Sätze
Sohn ohne nien macht blind in Bayern glaubst du
[Applaus] [Musik] sowas hey
s kein Scheiß ich bin damals zwei
Wochen später mit meiner Mutter
spazieren gegangen im Park ne ist uns ein Blinder
entgegengekommen ich habe mir
gedacht der hat's durchgezogen yes
[Musik] hey man wird so erzogen ich komme
aus Bayern versteht ihr da hey ich habe
8 Jahre bayerisches klostergymnasium
überlebt 8 Jahre christliche Marines ich
hatte 8 Jahre lateinbayerisches Hardcore
Mörder Latinum ja habt ihr Latein gehabt
8 Jahre Latein ich könnte heute auf
Lateinisch nicht einm Pizza bestellen
ruf mal an beim Italiener du Dom wo bist Pizza
du arslock du verpiss Dich perverse Sau h
8 Jahre Latein ich kann nicht mal Fluchen auf
Lateinisch wie gerne hätte ich früher zu meinem
Lateinlehrer gesagt jo teacher [__]
you aber wie auf Lateinisch du Magister
popare ist schwer wi ja gut ich bin 66er Jahrgang
wir sind damals noch geschlagen worden in der
Schule jetzt Mitleid oder Anerkennung aber
komm na kein Scheiß da vierte fünfte Klasse
war ganz klar die besten Schläger waren die
katholischen Religionslehrer und ich habe damals
meine erste externe Warche bekommen von meinem
Religionslehrer Kaplan Rüb der hieß wirklich
so ja und we der hat voll zugehauen
damals we so und danach kam wir immer
dieser berühmte after warelpruch
das tut mir mehr we als dir mein
[Applaus] [Musik] Sohn h meins ihr
kennt die zwei moralischen Stufen
der Erziehung also erst kommen die Eltern
und sagen ohanieren macht blind dann kommt
die Kirche und sagt wenn du Sex hast mit
einer Frau unverheiratet dann komm kommst
du in die Hölle also bestenfalls
werde ich irgendwann ein Blinder
[Applaus] [Musik] höllenwichser passiert
nmer ich habe es weitergebracht ich bin
jetzt verheiratet ich darf
offiziell sind verheiratet
hier ja meldet euch wo hey verheiratet sein ist
toll bitteschön für mich als Katholik zum ersten
mal poppen ohne schlechtes Gewissen was habe ich
früher gelitten Hölle Hölle AUA Hölle Hölle Hölle
hey ich hat schon mal das Gefühl dass der teufling
Gestalt von Wolfgang Petri neben mein betth Hoock
und mich auspeitscht mit so neunchwänzigen
freundschaftspendern Hölle Hölle Hölle ja und
jetzt könnt ihr uns Bayern vielleicht ein bisschen
besser verstehen danke schön [Applaus] dan